what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we could be getting
some new Marvel trailers really really
soon and it looks like Marvel could be
going all out and we could actually be
getting multiple trailers for not just
one project for phase five but multiple
and we're talking movies and shows but
specifically we are talking about the
possibility of getting the very first
teaser trailer for the Marvels now right
now we are about six months away from
the Marvels which means that trailer
should actually be coming relatively
soon so this rumor of when it's going to
be coming is actually lining up with
what Marvel typically does even more so
when you realize that Marvel is going to
air this on one of the stations that
Disney owns and of course Disney owns
Marvel Studios as well and it looks like
we could be getting these new trailers
during the Super Bowl for those of you
who may not be aware the Super Bowl is
going to take place on Sunday February
12th so less than a month away and it's
go into air on Fox which Disney now owns
which means they could put trailers
during the Super Bowl spots now don't
get me wrong even if they didn't own Fox
they could have bought spots as well
simply paid for the advertisements which
they still basically have to do but this
means that they are guaranteed a slot
and this is true Marvel fashion each
Super Bowl year we've had so far in the
past couple of years actually probably
more than that they've shown us
something for their up and coming Marvel
movies and now shows with Disney plus
and it looks like this year is going to
be no different as rumors are already
starting to go around that we could be
getting multiple trailers now there
could be two types of formats which
we'll talk about in just a bit but first
let's talk about what to expect Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania is going to be
right around the corner less than a week
away when the Super Bowl airs so I'm
assuming we're going to get some sort of
a special clip for Ant-Man quantumania
that seems to be kind of a given I
wouldn't expect it to be a full trailer
by that time most of the full trailers
will already have been out out but this
is a perfect opportunity to show an
actual clip which Disney and Marvel
Studios are known to do so that's what I
would expect for quantumania however the
others I'm expecting trailers the movie
coming up after quantumania is going to
be Guardians of the Galaxy 3. now again
at that point in time we'll be pretty
close to the release date for that so
maybe not a full trailer maybe another
clip however there is something that you
have to keep in mind Marvel and Disney
aren't going to have a ton of spots
they're probably going to get two maybe
even just one so these are the two
different scenarios scenario one is
going to be they're going to get two
slots and what will most likely happen
is they will promote Ant-Man and the
wasp quantumania and then the other slot
is going to be dedicated to multiple
different projects they have coming out
and in that promo we would see multiple
different clips for secret Invasion Loki
season 2 Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
and the Marvels now right now the rumor
is that we'll see a trailer for the
Marvels however like I said they're not
gonna get infinite amounts of spots
probably only one or two so I'm not
expecting a complete full trailer for
the Marvels however I am expecting to
see a lot of footage for the Marvels now
the other option is they get one slot
and in that case they're going to show
kind of just everything Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 secret Invasion Loki 2 and the
Marvels Disney is known for doing this
to kind of give us a little tease of
everything that's going to come in fact
they did it last week for phase five
they gave us a phase five trailer
however since Marvel has a lot coming
out and phase 4 was kind of a bust for
some fans I'm thinking they might go all
out in the Super Bowl I'm thinking that
we might get two slots and one of them
could show us some special footage from
Ant-Man and some other projects and then
one could indeed be just a trailer for
the Marvels to get everybody excited for
that movie and everybody hyped up
because at that point in time since
Ant-Man quantumania is going to be so
close people are going to be hyped up
for it then they show us some footage
for Guardians 3 secret Invasion Loki
season 2 to get us hyped for that but
the full trailer for the Marvels and
that is a possibility another
possibility is somehow they might
actually get three slots in which we
might get a trailer or quantumania a
sneak peek there a little highlight reel
for phase five for the other projects
and then a trailer for the Marvels now I
think this is the least likely to happen
simply because Super Bowl spots are
crazy expensive and in high demand and
very hard to get but again when you own
the company that the spots are going to
air on it's a little bit easier for you
so not likely but still entirely
possible either way we're going to be
getting some new looks at some of these
upcoming projects some new footage some
new trailers and it's going to be pretty
great so be sure to tune in for the
Super Bowl again it is February 12th
which is of course on a Sunday and it's
going to start at 6 30 PM eastern time
and of course after Marvel Studios
releases them during the Super Bowl they
pretty much come out during the same
time on YouTube so 1 6 30 Eastern Time
hits be sure to monitor YouTube be sure
to monitor Fox and of course subscribe
to my channel and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on the
breakdowns afterwards don't forget to
like this video and leave us your
comments down below so we know how you
feel about this and of course for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf